hollywood legend william shatner knows
oh so well
gentlemen beat me aboard star trek it
was a game changing show
something as simple as interracial kiss
that's you
nothing wrong with that man at 89
shatner has reached
icon status from star trek to
commercials
seriously i'm trusting you the man is
worth an estimated 100 million bucks
and did you know the emmy winner is also
a grammy nominated recording artist
william shatner the blues number one on
billboard
no come on number one on blues
what does a canadian guy from montreal
know about the blues
in his new music video he gets
you cause animated mine how do you
explain the shatner touch
the ideal is to mix
words and music i can't sing don't tell
anybody
e.t goes way back with bill in the early
80s we were with him on set
of his series tj hooker it's good to be
riding a winner
you got a chance to work with heather
locklear what was it like working with
her
oh come on yeah she's beautiful one of
our units will pick them up in no time
then we're back to real costs well
that's what i think she was 19 when i
knew her
and then as she did more and more she
got better and better at it
shatner himself keeps getting better
he's raising money for a good cause
even in the pandemic the hollywood
charity horse show we've had to cancel
the show this year every penny we get
goes to all these charities in
california
kids veterans by the way mr shatner told
me the sponsors are still donating and
so are lots of other people
if you want to get involved go to
[Music]
horseshow.org